في غضون ذلك قالت الامم المتحده ان
مساعداتها تنتظر دخول مناطق شمال غربي
سوريا واشار فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده الى ان
المنظمه الدوليه تساعد في حشد فرق الطوارئ
وعمليات الاغاثه في سوريا وتركيا واضاف ان
فرق الامم المتحده الخاصه بتقييم الكوارث
والتنسيق موجوده في المناطق المتضرره في
تركيا اضافه الى فريق سيصل الى سوريا
للدعم هناك
انتشر اكثر من 40 فريق بحث وانقاذ من
تركيا وتسعه عشره دوله اخرى يجري تنسيق
بين هذه الفرق من قبل الوكاله التركيه
لاداره الكوارث وفريق اممي مؤلف من 45
موظفا ينتشرون في المناطق المتضرره فريق
منفصل لتقييم الكوارث والتنسيق تابع للامم
المتحده في طريقه الى سوريا لدعم
الاستجابه هناك في شمال غرب سوريا في رقل
انقاذ منخرطه بشكل كامل في عمليات البحث
في جهات اخرى من سوريا هناك حاجه ملحه
للمساعده ولفرق الانقاذ الماهره والمساعده
اللوجستيه
على سؤال الجزيره بشان الحاجه لفتح معابر
اضافيه الى جانب معبر باب الهوى دعا فرحان
حق مجلس الامن الدولي لبحث المساله وتفهم
الحاجه الى ادخال مزيدا من المساعدات الى
المناطق المنكوبه في سوريا نتيجه الزلزال
الامر لا يتعلق بالسلطات السوريه بقدر ما
يتعلق بالولايه التي منحها لنا مجلس الامن
فيما يخص نقاط العبور ونامل بالتاكيد ان
ينظر المجلس في الوضع على الارض ويفهم
الحاجه الى التفكير في طرق لادخال المزيد
من المساعدات الى المنطقه باسرع وقت
بالطبع نترك هذا الامر في ايديهم لكنكم
سمعتم ما قاله الامير العام للامم المتحده
مرارا وتكرارا بشان اهميه ادخال المساعدات
عبر الحدود زملائنا في الميدان اكدوا
امكانيه الوصول الى معبر باب الهواء